hey it's sherrod small comedian handsome
and this is
answer the internet
if you could have one per one person
narrate or do
play by play of you having sex who would
it be
i would say marv albert because we got a
lot of the same technique
in the bedroom yeah we teethy
[Laughter]
next one how many rats would it take to
overwhelm
and kill you in a fight how many rats um
i'll say a dozen you know i think they
could take me down
they could eat all my flesh it's like
pigs like having hogs it's like snatch
the movie
don't ever trust a man with hogs or pigs
don't ever trust a man with a bunch of
rats
are you talking new york city rats or
regular oh city rats city rats the ones
you name
like junior
anything this size is don't even bring
it up if you see it like this
and they got a pizza a slice of pizza
going to the train that's a rat
if it were if it was acceptable for men
to carry purses
what would you carry in your purse oh i
would put everything in my purse
just like i would put everything in my
vagina if i had one and i mean
everything my keys
uh playing cards uh my bike
my friend's bikes this season
everything's looking a little bit
different
sports looks different the game looks
different it feels different but
lebaplus is trying to make sure things
stay as normal as possible making sure
that fans hashtag
gear up today's the bat blue featured
question of the night
is can you use a gift card on your first
date
uh yeah definitely because you're gonna
need that money for birth control
okay can you use a gift card on a first
date i say yes
why not you can use a gift card it
depends on what the gift is though right
if the gift is uh for like you know i
don't know
for applebee's don't do that what is
that
if you're on a first date now because
you're in trouble anyway you might as
well just [ __ ]
let it rip but maybe applebee's is what
she wanted maybe she's my kind of
trailer park chick
it reminds me of the prom and our
parents wedding
[Laughter]
okay would you rather fight mike tyson
sound like him for the rest of your life
fight him i can't walk around sounding
like i sucked on helium all day
he will kill you in a fight he'll
probably kill me but it'll be just for
two seconds it'll be two seconds i'm
unconscious
best sleep of my life wake up i go about
my my time
sounding like myself let's say he he
knocked you out
you have like some level of brain damage
for the rest of your life
i always have a good story to tell you
know how i got like this
my guys drool
[Laughter]
okay would you rather be uh stuck in
jurassic park or jumanji
uh jumanji huh
i go back and forth on this one it's
hard because you know
will [ __ ] you up but it's just dinosaurs
like jumanji is everything man jumping
plants
yeah stampedes but you know roberto
guns robin williams was a friend so i
would feel like i'm doing something for
robin
would you would you bang your cousin to
win a powerball
i banged my cousin already for no
powerball
say what now i mean it was like a
married and cousin
you know how many like a first cousin no
no no
it wasn't i'm not an animal it was by
marriage it was by marriage cousin okay
and i was like that's the cousin she's
like no that's what's his name daughter
and she i was like okay she had the
family reunion so i think everybody's
related so you
you did it and then found out no i knew
no i
i knew and then did it i found out no
you know what i'm saying knowingly
banged your cousin
no i knew she wasn't by marriage it was
only by marriage
if you see her you be like this all
right yeah
yeah so i guess for powerball then it's
a definite yes
yeah yeah yeah for politics what if it
was not through marriage but you get
powerball
um no well it depends on a cousin
is he cute
uh is sex with a conjoined twins a
threesome
yes it depends on where they they can
join that
huh cause they can join at the vagina is
a no sum
who's getting there that's heavy traffic
you can do that holland tunnel all right
if you had a hot stalker
uh who was crazily obsessed with you
would you [ __ ] her have
yes well yeah yeah but only [ __ ] i want
you about to move
get away you know what i'm saying as
soon as your lease is up you'll be like
this hey
what you up to tonight so you know what
the problem is though like they
the internet and everything now it's
like they'll find you they can used to
be like
i'm moving neighborhoods you're never
gonna see me again whatever but now
and that's why i never put location on
my pictures on the internet
i don't need that kind of business
nobody's showing up yeah but if you
about to move and she's still gonna be
like this come bang me and then help me
move this couch
kill two birds would you rather wake up
in the middle of the night to see
a massive dude has broken into your
house or to see a ghost
ghost because a ghost can't [ __ ] you
a massive dude i'm just like cop all
right let's hurry up
ghost is gonna say boo [ __ ] you
if you could pick one country to run
what would it be
iceland why is that
i don't know i thought it sounded weird
[Laughter]
i mean i'll go to reykjavik
there's a whole bunch of blondies there
yeah i'd be in reykjavik running through
them
they wouldn't know they'll think i'm
[ __ ] will smithers they don't know uh
which activity takes more physical
more physical fitness golf or porn porn
definitely the stuff i watch oh it's
heavy-handed
ooh i like it handed
but i'm talking like a full weekend
let's say you're in a tournament you
know
full like 18 every day you're walking
miles i get it
in golf you do 18 holes but i've seen
porn with more than 18 homes
and it was all full a hole in one most
of them
uh would you watch a porn star who had
your mom's name
yeah long she ain't got my mom's face
and social security number
uh would you trade lives with magic
johnson or just stay yourself
man i would trade lives with magic and
i mean everything that comes with it i
would take everything that came with it
he's over aids yeah
i mean magic's aids come with [ __ ]
movie theaters
my not a's don't so i'm gonna take that
a's baby
get my mama house who's more dominant
kinions and marathons are indians and
spelling bees
that's tight that's two tight minorities
races right there got some kenyans who
beaten kenyans in a
and they do a barefoot it's like what in
the name of black panther
but them indians and spelling bees i
can't even spell their names
they over here spelling words in english
i can't spell
whoa
i'm gonna say indians you know why
because sometimes
kenyans get beat by ethiopians but you
never saw
indians getting beat by pakistanis boom
earth
[Laughter]
yes
you